a lot of people saying oh i can't wait  to get back to normal do you ever think  there will be back to normal or will  there be a new normal there'll be a new  normal it's impossible i am not going to  travel as much i'm going to see my  children  at their school functions all the time  because i'm going to do my business call  on the phone zoom where that was  difficult before because the business  associated wanted to meet  in person but now she or he will be open  not always  and i won't be there'll be times where i  still fly to dubai for one meeting  but there will be absolutely times where  i have three meetings in dubai  that would have required a trip that  won't